the pond sounds like it is the humblest
of chess pieces but it is really one of
the most powerful when working together
pawns are the soul of chess pawns have a
few strange rules so make sure to pay
attention pawns can only move straight
forward and they can only move one
square at a time however if it is their
first move of the game they can choose
to move two squares forward if there is
nobody blocking them as pawns cannot
jump over other pieces remember the pawn
can choose to advance one or two squares
only on the first move on all other
moves the pawn advances one Square pawns
are also the only piece and chess that
cannot move backwards one other thing
that makes them strange is that while
they cannot move straight forward pawns
can only capture diagonally and they can
only capture one square away diagonally
even if it is their first turn we will
explain capturing in one of the next
lessons
let's see some pawn moves in this
position since this pawn has yet to move
in the game white decides to move at two
squares forward black on the other hand
only advances this pawn one Square
remember even though you can move your
pawn two squares on its first move
you're not forced to do so white now
advances the pawn forward and now both
pawns are blocked and cannot move in
this position how many white pawns can
move if you said one you're correct
notice that this pawn is blocked by the
black pawn directly in front of it
remember pawns cannot move backwards
white now has the option to move this
pawn up one square notice this pawn
cannot move two squares forward because
the black pawn blocks it now it's your
turn to practice using the pawns